but nine since I was four hours
gonna be shooting in star wars film I
would have planned a all my life this
film this character is the story I grew
up with it's a whole world I've been
thinking about from quite a long time
you can feel everyone in the career in
the class kind of stops and just take
that in and you remember were actually
in Star Wars it's like the world's
greatest toy set it's a bit like being
that kid again the Star Wars figures
still troopers over here and this
happens is an explosion it's been a lot
of fun it's the greatest job in the
world
Brooklyn takes place very close to
episode four
the simplest way to explain that is that
text you see at the beginning of a new
hope
that is essentially a movie
they call it the death star terrible
weapon but there's a way to defeat it
Jin starting to put together a team she
wants to fight we all do
I'm only doing it it isn't ensemble
movie but at the heart there's a strong
woman the time to fight is now every day
they grow stronger
all these characters are real heroes
that are willing to risk everything like
the police huh
I make 10 men fit like a hundred through
their journey we see the formation of
the Rebel Alliance and the stealing of
the Death Star plans you are not willing
to risk be left behind
as a chance to speak up that is a bad
idea they achieve what they achieved
because they achieve it together
this is wrote one
you
we have a mission for you a major
weapons test is imminent we need to know
how to destroy